Is your mom home? I was hoping to speak with your mom.
She's in Barcelona.
Of course she is.
Is there anything else I can help you with?
Actually, I was wondering.
What made you think it was a good idea to
orchestrate an orgy in me and my husband's bedroom?
That was Rae's idea.
That's bullshit.
Maybe you weren't aware that
she's completely obsessed with me.
I mean, why do you think she decided to start going
by her middle name?
What?
I said Rae was cooler.
I can't help that she's in love with me.
Look, you little entitled fucking pretentious little fucking dipshit.
First of all, her name is not for you to change.
Second, if someone is in love with you, you treat them with respect.
Are you sure you don't want a towel?
You treat their heart like you are holding a
fucking day-old duckling whose neck could break at any fucking second.
Okay?
My God. Duckling? Are you, like, 50?
No, I'm fucking 49 years old, and I know how to have a
fucking threesome. Not that pathetic little
pussy ass shit!
That's offensive and self-hating.
Do you have any idea how fucking
lucky you are to be loved by her?
I would fucking kill to have a fucking ounce of that
love, and she wastes it on you?
What kind of fucking name is Montana? Who are you? Fucking
Brad Pitt in fucking River Runs Through It
thinking everyone wants to fuck you because you have fucking great hair.
Okay. Your. That child was filming this so
you could ask him to fucking kindly delete it
from apps. All the apps.
Hey, guys. What's wrong?
You!
Just don't.
There's a TikTok.
Of course there is.
Honey, can I-
Okay. If you want to talk about anything, I'm right-
I'm right here-
I won't! Ever!